[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Mitri Siri in allen einen schönen guten
Abend mit mir im Studio wieder Norbert
später mit allen wichtigen vom Sport
schönen guten Abend auch von mir und das
sind unsere heutigen Themen
Gedenken an Massa Amini ein Jahr nach
dem Tod der jungen Frau reagiert Irans
Regie mit strengen
Sicherheitsvorkehrungen
schwierige Situation auf Lampedusa
kommissionspräsidentin von der Leyen
will die Insel besuchen Italien fordert
ein Eingreifen der EU um die Migranten
zu stoppen
und Sturm auf die Wiesen das Münchner
Oktoberfest ist eröffnet diesmal dauert
die Gaudi 2 Tage länger
[Musik]
strengste Sicherheitsvorkehrungen
überall Militär in Iran ist die
Anspannung vor allem im machterparat zu
spüren zum ersten Mal hier hat sich der
Todestag von Massa Amini der jungen
Kurden die unfreiwillig zur protestikone
wurde
sittenlechter hatten sie vor einem Jahr
festgenommen angeblich hatte sie ihr
Kopftuch nicht vorschriftsgemäß getragen
die 22-Jährige brach in Polizeigewahrsam
zusammen und starb kurz darauf im
Krankenhaus ihr Tod löste die schwersten
Proteste seit Jahrzehnten in Iran aus
mehrere Menschen wurden hingerichtet
tausende verhaftet aus Teheran berichtet
Jörg Brase
bis Einbruch der Dunkelheit war es ruhig
in Irans Hauptstadt am Todestag von
Marsa Amini liegt eine Anspannung über
teerer viele Läden blieben tagsüber
geschlossen das ist heute
Demonstrationen geben könnte damit
rechnet wegen der Sicherheitsmaßnahmen
kaum jemand das Land aber hätte sich
durch die Proteste nach aminist tot
bereits verändert sagen viele dass ich
heute meinen Kopftuch unbehelligt nur
auf den Schultern tragen kann sagt diese
Frau nach über 40 Jahren das ist ein
großer Fortschritt
ob wir Kopftuch tragen müssen oder nicht
ist mir gar nicht so wichtig meint diese
junge Frau es gibt viele andere Dinge in
unserer Gesellschaft die Frauen unter
Druck setzen und uns Probleme machen und
dagegen müssen wir uns sehen
massamin ist tot war der Tropfen der das
fast zum überlaufen brachte sie wurde
zum Symbol der Proteste gegen die
Kopftuch Pflicht gegen hohe Preise gegen
das Regie das schlug den volkszahn
brutal nieder auch vor dem heutigen
Jahrestag hatte es zahlreiche
Verhaftungen von Regimekritikern und
strafan Drohungen gegeben
dieser raus sein das sind alles Zeichen
der Schwäche nicht der Stärke würde sich
das Regime stark fühlen würde es sich
nicht dauernd verteidigen wer meint sich
verteidigen zu müssen der macht sich
große Sorgen
in massa Amelies Heimatstadt sakes wurde
heute ihr Vater unter Druck gesetzt
keine Trauerzeremonie abzuhalten man
will unbedingt verhindern dass es an
diesem Tag stration kommt
Jörg Brase ist uns jetzt zugeschaltet
erster Todestag von Massa Amini Jörg wie
erlebst du die Situation auf Teherans
Straßen
ja also was wir jetzt hier hören gerade
das sind auch einige hubkonzerte so wie
man sie über den Protesten vor einem
Jahr auch gehört hat aber große
Menschenansammlung die haben wir heute
nicht gesehen dafür aber massive
Sicherheitsvorkehrungen wir haben
gesehen dass Tausende von
Sicherheitskräften hier aufgezogen sind
die Universitäten die befinden sich in
einem waren Belagerungszustand das heißt
man versucht tatsächlich zu verhindern
dass es heute hier zu Demonstrationen
kommt aber man muss sagen das ist hier
im Land durchaus Veränderung gegeben hat
wer mit vielen Frauen gesprochen die uns
gesagt haben dass sie heute sehr viel
selbstbewusster als früher für ihre
Rechte eintreten und das sie auch
zunehmend Zuspruch bekommen von den
Männern wir haben gehört dass es im
politischen Raum Streit geben soll darum
wie man mit den Forderungen der Menschen
nun umgehen sollten es ist klar dass man
deren Unzufriedenheit nicht auf Dauer
mit Gewalt unterdrücken kann also ein
Jahr nach massa-amini ist tot scheint
sich hier im Land doch einiges bewegt zu
haben danke nach Tiran Jörg Preise und
auch in mit mehreren deutschen
Großstädten haben heute tausende
Menschen an die junge Iranerin erinnert
allein in Berlin gab es verschiedene
Kundgebungen und Demonstrationen die
Teilnehmer solidarisierten sich mit den
Iranern die weiter gegen das
mulla-regime Aufbegehren zudem
demonstrierten sie für weibliche
Selbstbestimmung in Iran
ein altes Problem bringt neuen Druck
nach dem tausende geflüchtete auf der
völlig überlasteten italienischen Insel
Lampedusa ankamen ruft Italiens
Ministerpräsidentin die EU zur Hilfe sie
fordert migrantenbote auf dem Weg nach
Europa zu stoppen notfalls durch die
Marine eine weitere Zuspitzung des
Konflikts möchte
eu-kommissionspräsidentin von der Leyen
unbedingt vermeiden und reiste deswegen
zu Gesprächen nach Italien
hatte das Gerücht die Runde gemacht ein
zweites Lager werde auf einer ehemaligen
Militärbasis der Insel aufgebaut
zusätzlich zu dem Durchgangslager dass
die letzten Tage komplett überfüllt war
die Reaktion Wut und Empörung
von heute an sagt Lampedusa genug wir
wollen nicht mehr die Botschaft die
sowohl an die EU als auch an die
italienische Regierung übermittelt
werden muss ist die Menschen von
Lampedusa sind es leid
das Gerücht erwies sich als unkorrekt
darauf der Insel liegen die Nerven blank
die italienischen Behörden Arbeiten
derweil mit Hochdruck daran die Lage zu
normalisieren bringen die Migranten per
fairen aufs Festland auch heute wieder
über 2.500 Menschen
tausende von Migranten waren in den
letzten Woche mit Booten angekommen sie
waren in Tunesien an Bord gegangen
Italiens Ministerpräsidentin Georgia
Meloni forderte jetzt die im EU Tunesien
migrationsabkommen zugesagte
millionenhilfe an Tunesien auszuzahlen
damit das Land seinen Verpflichtungen
nachkommt für den nächsten EU-Gipfel im
Oktober plant sie zudem noch mehr
ich habe den Präsidenten des
Europäischen Rates gebeten das
migrationsthema auf die Tagesordnung zu
setzen ich werde bei dieser Gelegenheit
bekräftigen dass es notwendig ist sofort
eine EU marine-mission ins Leben zu
rufen um die Abfahrt von migrantenboden
zu blockieren
noch heute soll sich Meloni in Rom mit
eu-kommissionspräsidentin von der Leyen
Treffen morgen wollen sie dann gemeinsam
nach Lampedusa reisen
wir gehen nach Brüssel zu ultra Ulf der
Umgang mit geflüchteten ist ein
europäisches dauert immer was will von
der Leyen mit ihrem italienbesuch
erreichen
also ich glaube die
kommissionspräsidentin will sehr
deutlich machen dass das eben kein
italienisches Problem ist sondern ein
europäisches Problem deswegen reißt sie
dort auch hin und es gibt noch ein
anderes krisensgespräch hat es heute
gegeben der EU Innenminister die haben
eine Telefonkonferenz gehabt um die
haben auch klar gesagt wir müssen uns
drum kümmern wir können Italien nicht
alleine lassen der erste Schritt den man
jetzt machen will ist noch mal Druck auf
Tunesien ausüben Tunesien ist dieser
schlüsselstaat es gibt ja den Versuch
eines Abkommens das eben nicht so viele
Migranten mehr aus Tunesien nach Italien
kommen dafür soll es viele viele
Millionen antonesien geben aber dieses
Abkommen kommt nicht richtig zustande
und da hat jetzt noch mal von alleine
den Auftrag bekommen der EU aus EU
Innenminister noch mal deutlich mehr
Druck zu machen sprich vielleicht auch
mehr Geld noch mal zu zahlen das Problem
ist das Tunesien selber sagt die
Flüchtlinge das ist eine zu große
Belastung für unsere Gesellschaft und
das scheint die Gesellschaft zu springen
also keiner will diese Flüchtlinge haben
wie gesagt trotzdem wird man versucht
mit Tunesien jetzt endlich dieses
Abkommen ihm zu kriegen um eine Stelle
Lösung zu finden vielen Dank nach
Brüsseler
ja in Brüssel wurde im Mammutprozess um
die islamistischen Terroranschläge vor
sieben Jahren das vorerst letzte Urteil
gesprochen das Gericht verhängte gegen
mehrere Männer wegen Mordes und
versuchten Mordes Haftstrafen zwischen
10 Jahren und lebenslänglich bei den
Anschlägen am 22 März 2016 am Brüsseler
Flughafen und in einer U-Bahn-Station
wurden 35 Menschen getötet Hunderte
verletzt
in Stuttgart ist es bei einer
Veranstaltung der dortigen Eritrea
Vereine zu heftigen Ausschreitungen
gekommen Gegner und Befürworter der
eritreischen Regierung gerieten
aneinander griffen sich gegenseitig und
Polizisten mit Steinen Flaschen und
Holzlatten an dabei wurden zehn Beamte
verletzt die Polizei setzte Schlagstöcke
und Pfefferspray ein mehrere Personen
wurden festgenommen ja Angriffe auf
Einsatzkräfte das kommt immer öfter vor
im vergangenen Jahr mindestens 80.000
mal dazu zählen körperliche Attacken
auch mit schweren Verletzungen
Beleidigungen oder Widerstand vor allem
betroffen Polizistinnen und Polizisten
weit vor Rettungskräften und
Feuerwehrleuten so eine Umfrage des
redaktionsnetzwerk ist Deutschland
nach der Flutkatastrophe in Libyen sind
inzwischen etwa 4000 Tote identifiziert
weil noch viele tausend Menschen
vermisst werden dürfte die Toten Zahl
weiter ansteigen eine Woche nach den
verheerenden Überschwemmungen droht die
Gefahr von solchen besonders das zeigt
uns jetzt Stefanie Gareis in der am
stärksten betroffenen Hafenstadt drinne
eine Schneise des Todes die sich dadurch
die Hafenstadt der nazid vor gerade mal
fünf Tagen standen hier Häuser dicht
besiedelt dann kam die Flutwelle
verursacht durch den Bruch zweier Dämmer
und nun bat sich schon die nächste Krise
an herum fliegender müllchemikalien und
auch die Toten die noch nicht geborgen
wurden verunreinigen das Wasser
Krankheiten wie die Cholera machen sich
breit eine schwere Magen-Darm-Erkrankung
die ohne die richtige Behandlung zum
Tode führen kann es braucht schnelle
Hilfe Medikamente und sauberes Wasser
vieles ist bereits wie hier in Bengasi
angekommen doch gerne mehr als 300 km
entfernt hat vieles noch nicht erreicht
wir sind bereits in der Koordination
Essen und lebenswichtige Güter zu
verteilen auch Material um einen
sicheren Wasserzugang zu ermöglichen
ebenso wie spezielle Medikamente die
gerade hier angekommen sind
viele in der Stadt sagen jetzt sei noch
nicht der richtige Zeitpunkt um nach den
Schuldigen zu suchen es gebe
Dringenderes doch gleichzeitig berichten
sie von Nachlässigkeiten der Behörden
die libysche Staatsanwaltschaft hat die
Ermittlungen bereits aufgenommen
die Untersuchung befassen sich unter
anderem damit wohin die
instandhaltungsgelder für die beiden
Staudämme geflossen sind wir prüfen
sowohl lokale Behörden als auch
Regierungsstellen
bis dahin aber geht die Suche nach den
tausenden vermissten weiter beim Anblick
dieser Bilder eine schwierige Aufgabe
die Menschen in Libyen brauchen Hilfe
wenn sie spenden dann können Sie das tun
über das Aktionsbündnis
Katastrophenhilfe die IBAN lautet de
6500 Stichwort ZDF Nothilfe Libyen Infos
auch auf spenden.zdf.de und auf der ZDF
Text Seite 89.0
in Afghanistan haben die radikal
islamischen Taliban Angestellte einer
Schweizer Hilfsorganisation festgenommen
sie hätten 21 Menschen in Gewahrsam
genommen so die Regierung die NGO
spricht von 18 Mitarbeitern die aus dem
Büro nach Kabul gebracht wurden und weiß
den Vorwurf sie wollten Afghanen zum
Christentum bekehren zurück
international assistance Mission ist
seit mehr als 50 Jahren in Afghanistan
aktiv
jetzt zum Krieg in der Ukraine der
Global viele wirtschaftliche
Auswirkungen hat erzählt die
eu-handelsbeschränkungen für ukrainische
Getreideprodukte auf allerdings haben
Polen Ungarn und die Slowakei
angekündigt am Importstopp festhalten
weil sie die eigene Landwirtschaft
gefährdet sehen sie erlauben nur den
Weitertransport dass sie die Ukraine
weiter in allen Bereichen unterstützen
wollen sicherten gestern
bundesaußenministerin Werbung und ihre
us-kollege blinken zu niemand werde sich
an einem brutalen Angriffskrieg gewöhnen
so Bewerbung
eine immer wichtigere Rolle im Krieg
spielte Einsatz von Drohnen sie sind
leicht zu bedienen variabel einsetzt war
und vergleichsweise günstig die
umbenannten Flugobjekte haben Russland
und der Ukraine schon herbe Verluste und
Schäden zugefügt beide Staaten arbeiten
ständig daran die Drohnen effizienter zu
machen wie das die Ukraine tut konnte
sich Hannah Streit anschauen
am Himmel über der Ukraine tobt der
Krieg der Drohnen wir versuchen die
Verteidiger solch einen russischen
Flugkörper voller Sprengstoff
abzuschießen
am Ende mit Erfolg
doch auch ukrainische Truppen entwickeln
eigene Drohnen Walküre heißt dieses
Gerät aus Styropor zu Erkundung des
Schlachtfelds es geht darum Leben zu
retten das ist das wertvollste daher
haben die Drohnen die Situation vehement
verändert und werden das auch weiter tun
Walküre wird zur Aufklärung eingesetzt
sie soll russische Geschütze finden
bevor die ihr vorher eröffnen können
allerdings hat China die Lieferung
wichtiger Bauteile inzwischen nahezu
eingestellt
wir haben das schon kommen sehen und
beschlossen alle wichtigen und
kritischen Bauteile selbst herzustellen
es ist ein Rüstungswettlauf gegen
Russlands drohnenbauer den Sie ihn gut
versteckten Werkstätten bei Kiew führen
hier entwickelt sie auch Langstrecken
Drohnen doch die halten sie nicht für
kriegsen entscheidend
sein die Zerstörung eines Gebäudes ist
wirtschaftlich aber weniger sinnvoll als
die Vernichtung eines Panzers oder eines
gegnerischen artilleriesystems für
mehrere Millionen Dollar
in diesem Krieg geht es beiden Seiten
darum mit einem Minimum an Material dem
Gegner so viel Schaden zuzufügen wie
möglich
in Russland zugelassene Fahrzeuge dürfen
nicht mehr in das Gebiet der EU
einfahren diese Sanktionsmaßnahmen hatte
die EU vergangene Woche klargestellt und
immer mehr Länder setzen Sie jetzt um um
Mitternacht hat zuletzt Finnland die
Kontrollen verschärft Fahrzeuge mit
russischen Nummernschildern kommen nicht
mehr ins Land das gilt auch schon für
die baltischen Staaten Polen zieht ab
morgen nach
am Ende eines Oktoberfestes sind
normalerweise durchschnittlich über
sieben Millionen Liter Bier getrunken
worden gut möglich dass es wegen der
Preise diesmal ein paar Liter weniger
werden von heute an wird jedenfalls
wieder zweieinhalb Wochen lang das
größte Volksfest der Welt gefeiert mit
top-hosen sprinten zumindest heute
Claudia Vogelmann
als gäbe es etwas umsonst Ansturm auf
das oktoberfestgelände in München dabei
sind die diesem Jahr die Preise so hoch
wie nie seistrum beim Anstich waren
120.000 Plätze in den großen Festzelten
schnell belegt zwei eins und Ortschaft
ist außer friedliche Riesel mit zwei
Schlägen eröffnet Münchens
Oberbürgermeister Dieter Reiter das
Oktoberfest kurz nach 12 dann Bier für
alle die Maß kostet teuer von 12,60 €
bis 14,90 € in den 14,50 €
doll nee ja kann man sich ja mal leisten
auch die Speisen sind teurer geworden
selbstbewusst verteidigt der fest wird
der armer hühnerbraterei die Preise für
sein Bio-Geflügel das halbe Hähnchen zum
Mitnehmen bietet er für stolze 20 € 50
an dennoch ist es so dass die Gäste
bereit sind mehr für das Produkt zu
zahlen weil sie wissen dass es eine
super Qualität ist es gibt nichts
besseres andere halten die Preise bei
diesen Lebkuchenherzen sind sie gleich
geblieben 5 € für die kleine 55 für die
große Liebeserklärung zum ersten Mal hat
die Stadt eine einsehen und bietet
kostenloses Trinkwasser an doch die
Zapfsäulen stehen an er unappetitlichen
Orten der Weg zwischen Wasser lassen und
Wasser fassen ist hier sehr kurz 18 Tage
lang dauert die größte Biersauce der
Welt die Stadt erwartet in diesem Jahr
wieder mehr internationale Gäste die
Zeichen stehen gut
so wir machen mit einer Tischtennis
Europameisterschaft weiter eigentlich
mit zweien in Malmö nämlich bei den
Frauen und bei den Männern ja da waren
beide Teams sehr erfolgreich die sind ja
auch beide die Titel Verteidiger beide
mussten im Halbfinale heute gegen
Portugal antreten und beide siegten
stehen also im Finale die Männer gewann
mit drei zu eins die Frauen machen es
noch souveräner 3 zu 0 ohne einen
einzigen Satzverlust
Nina Mittel haben die im vergangenen
Jahr bei der einzel-em in München im
Finale unter Tränen verletzt aufgeben
musste macht den Anfang sie schlägt
Jenny Schau mit 3:0 als nächste an der
Platte Ying Hand die gegen for you
ebenfalls in drei Sätzen gewinnt und
auch xionasan als dritte dtb-spielerin
gewinnt gegen Ines martos mit 3:0
finalgegnerinnen die rumänischen Dauer
Rivalin Timo Boll der sein Auftakt
Mensch verloren hat sagt bei den Männern
dann doch für den entscheidenden Sieg im
Finale winkt der zehnte EM-Titel und die
direkte Olympiaqualifikation
gestern Abend furioser Auftrag der
Fußball-Bundesliga der Frauen das
Topspiel Freiburg gegen Bayern mit einem
Last Minute Ausgleich der
Breisgauerinnen gegen die Meisterin aus
München
es ist ein Flipper Tor das Freiburg in
der Nachspielzeit zum Punkt Gewinn hilft
doch trotz aller Emotion ist dieses Tor
diskutabel denn völlig springt der Ball
an den Unterarm die Körperfläche zwar
nicht vergrößert aber egal ob
absichtlich oder unabsichtlich bei Tor
Erzielung ist es Handspiel dabei war der
Auftakt in die neue Bundesliga-Saison
verheißungsvoll 13000 Zuschauer sehen
ein spannendes Spiel bis zu 91 Minute
steht es eins zu eins ehe die Bayern
vorlegen noch am Ende ist es eben dieses
umstrittene Tor das den Sieg der Gäste
verhindert
ja und auch bei den Männern musste
Bayern meist Meister Bayern München
gestern Abend den Last Minute Ausgleich
zum 2:2 in der Nachspielzeit einstecken
im Fußball Krimi gegen die Leverkusen
und hier die heutigen Ergebnisse des
vierten spieltags
Leipzig besiegt Augsburg 3:0 Freiburg
unterliegt Dortmund 2:4 Wolfsburg
schlägt Union 2:1 Mainz verliert gegen
Stuttgart 1:3 ebenso Köln gegen
Hoffenheim das Abendspiel Bochum gegen
Frankfurt kurzer Blick auf die Tabelle
Leverkusen weiter Tabellenführer vor den
punktgleichen Bayern dahinter Leipzig
Stuttgart Hoffenheim und Wolfsburg die
zweite Tabellenhälfte beginnt mit
Frankfurt und ganz unten Köln vor Mainz
und schlosslicht Darmstadt
das Abendspiel Bochum gegen Frankfurt
ausführlich bei uns zu sehen im
Aktuellen Sportstudio um 23:30 Uhr zu
Gast acht Spieler und der Trainer vom
deutschen Basketball Weltmeister Team
Gold für das deutsche bogenteam bei den
Invictus gehen Games den Spielen für im
Einsatz am Körper oder Seele verletzten
oder erkrankten Soldatinnen und Soldaten
Jens Niemeyer Kevin Kotka und Tom
Grunwald besiegten das Team aus Rumänien
ganz knapp im Finale hatte vorhin zuvor
im Kugelstoßen Geburt
sehr gut ja gratulation und du hast
jetzt noch ein paar schöne Royale Bilder
so ist es vielen Dank Norbert Schweden
feiert nämlich und zwar sein
monarchenkönig Karl Gustaf mit
entsprechend prächtiger Parade in
Stockholm immerhin ist Karl der 16
Gustav seit 50 Jahren auf dem Thron
seiner Seite Königin Silvia 3000
Soldaten eskortierten die offene Kutsche
begeisterte jubelt von vielen Schweden
am Abend da können sich dann alle in der
Hauptstadt noch ein großes Volksfest
samt Konzert freuen und mehr zum Thron
Jubiläum von Karl Gustav direkt nach uns
und dem Wetter in ZDF Royal das heute
journal mit Christian Sievers gibt's
heute um
23:15 Uhr das war's von uns schönen
Samstagabend und bis morgen
[Musik]
guten Abend unser Spätsommer hoch hat
sich jetzt schon recht weit in den Osten
verschoben so dass die Tiefs aus Westen
wieder an uns herankommen und zwar zum
einen mit etwas Regen zum anderen aber
auch noch mal mit richtig sommerlicher
Luft das spüren wir auch nachts heute
Nacht kühlt es zum Beispiel an der
Nordsee nur auf 17 Grad ab auch in der
Osthälfte bleiben wir meist zweistellig
bei bis zu 10 Grad dazu bildet sich an
Flussniederungen vor allem im Süden
etwas Nebel meist ist es aber klar im
Westen allerdings da ziehen Wolken mit
etwas Regen und auch kurzen Gewittern
heute Abend und in der Nacht vom
Saarland in Richtung Niedersachsen und
die kommen dann morgen Vormittag auch in
Richtung Nordsee voran generell im
Nordwesten und Westen gibt es morgen
etwas mehr Wolken es wird insgesamt aber
wieder ein sehr freundlicher Tag mit
meist nur lockeren oder hohen Wolken und
dazu gibt es eben verbreitet über 25
Grad an den Küsten um 23 Grad am
Hochrhein sind sogar 31
Grad möglich also sind Temperaturen wie
an einem Sommertag die erste
Septemberhälfte die kann wahrlich mit
den Sommermonaten mithalten ab Montag
allerdings Räumen Gewitter von West nach
Ost die hohen Temperaturen aus und dann
wird es windiger und unbeständiger und
damit auf Wiedersehen